"WE MUST GET THE DEMS TO GET
TOUGH ON THE BORDER, AND WITH
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION, FAST!"
ARE TWO BUSINESS DAYS AWAY FROM
THE PROSPECT OF ANOTHER
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
THE CLOCK RUNS OUT AT MIDNIGHT
THURSDAY.
MIKE EMANUEL TELLS US FROM
CAPITOL HILL NEITHER DEMOCRATS
NOR REPUBLICANS SEEM TO HAVE THE
WILL TO MAKE ANY KIND OF
LONG-TERM COMMITMENT.
>> THE ONLY REASON WE DO NOT
HAVE A FULL BUDGET AGREEMENT IS
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS CONTINUE TO
HOLD FUNDING FOR OUR GOVERNMENT
HOSTAGE ON AN UNRELATED ISSUE.
>> LAWMAKERS ARE VOTING ON THE
FIFTH CONTINUING RESOLUTION TO
FUND THE GOVERNMENT FROM
THURSDAY TO MARCH 23RD.
IT WOULD EXTEND FUNDING FOR A
NUMBER OF MEDICARE PIECES AND
CRITICAL PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS
INCLUDING COMMUNITY HEALTH
CENTERS.
>> IT’S TIME TO FOCUS ON MEETING
THESE ESSENTIAL SERVICES,
PARTICULARLY HEALTH CARE AND
HEALTH CARE SERVICES.
THEY ARE A LIFELINE FOR OUR
PEOPLE.
>> TO WIN OVER DEFENSE HOPS AND
CONSERVATIVES, THE EXTENSION
INCLUDES INCREASED MILITARY
FUNDING.
>> WE ARE GOING TO VOTE FOR THE
RIGHT THING.
THEY THINK IT’S MORE IMPORTANT
TO GIVE AMNESTY TO CERTAIN FOLKS
FOR WHATEVER REASON, WITH AND
GETS WRONG.
>> CHUCK SCHUMER DECLARED THE
PLAN DEAD ON ARRIVAL IN THE
SENATE, HOLDING OUT FOR MORE
DOMESTIC SPENDING.
BECAUSE ARMED SERVICES CLINIC ON
AN EAR FULL FROM OF DEFENSE,
WARNING FREQUENT PUTTING
RESOLUTIONS AND THE EXISTING
BUDGET CAPS ARE CAUSING THE
AMERICAN MILITARY ADVANTAGE TO
SHRINK.
>> THE COMBINATION OF RAPIDLY
CHANGING TECHNOLOGY, THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON MILITARY
READINESS RESULTING FROM THE
LONGEST CONTINUOUS STRETCH OF
COMBAT IN OUR NATIONS HISTORY,
AND INSUFFICIENT FUNDING, HAVE
CREATED AND OVERSTRETCHED AND
UNDER RESOURCED MILITARY.
>> IT MAY HELP THE CONGRESSIONAL
LEADERS WITH EFFORTS TO GET A
NEW LONG-TERM FUNDING AGREEMENT
WITH MORE MONEY FOR THE MILITARY
AND DOMESTIC PRIORITIES.
NEARLY $300 BILLION MORE FOR THE
NEXT TWO YEARS WHICH COULD GET
TALKED INTO A SHORT-TERM
EXTENSION.
>> I AM OPTIMISTIC WE WILL BE
ABLE TO REACH AN AGREEMENT.
>> I HAVE DISCUSSED SOME THE
OUTLINES WITH MY CAUCUS THAT I
THINK WE ARE HAPPY WITH.
HOPEFULLY THE REPUBLICANS ARE.
THEN WE CAN GET SOMETHING REALLY
GOOD DONE.
>> A BUDGET CAP AGREEMENT WOULD
MAKE MOST FEEL BETTER ABOUT
VOTING FOR A FIFTH TEMPORARY
GOVERNMENT FUNDING EXTENSION FOR
MORE SPENDING COULD CREATE NEW
HEADACHES FOR G.O.P. LEADERS
WHEN IT COMES TIME TO RAISE THE
DEBT CEILING IN THE COMING